OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE CANNABIS
NEWS NETWORK, JOE BIDEN KNEELED
TRUMP ON JUDGMENT ABOUT
COMMUNICATING.
PERFORM THE WAY HE DOES,
PARTICULARLY WITH TWEETS BUT NOT
JUST TWEETS.
WORDS MATTER.
THIS IS NOT A GAME.
CHEST?
IT'S NOT PRESIDENTIAL.
HE COULD SUPPLY AMERICANS
FUNNIEST HOME VIDEOS WITH THE
DECADE FULL OF FLUBS.
I KID, JOE.
WE KNOW WHAT HE'S UP TO.
HE IS TAKING HIS TOE IN THE POOL
OF THE NEXT ELECTION.
LET'S HOPE HE IS WEARING SWIM
TRUNKS THIS TIME.
HE TENDS TO FORGET THEM.
LABELING TRUMP'S RHETORIC IS NOT
PRESIDENTIAL, IT MISSES THE
POINT ENTIRELY THAT RHETORIC MAY
BE PROVIDING PROGRESS MISSING
WHEN BIDEN WAS TOO BUSY HUGGING
EVERYTHING THAT MOVED.
BIDEN SEEMS STUCK IN THE PAST.
FRED FLINTSTONE IN A JETSON
PARTY'S NEW BLOOD.
SINCE TRUMP UNLEASHED HIS
AMAZING THAT A TWICE DIVORCED
DUDE LIKE TRUMP IS SUCH A GOOD
MARRIAGE COUNSELOR.
DEALING WITH NORTH KOREA.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO SPEAK
CRAZY TO BEAT CRAZY AND IT'S
MORE PERSUASIVE THAN THE
ANALYSIS AND PARALYSIS THAT
CHARACTERIZED OBAMA'S CHIN
STROKING NAVEL-GAZING.
THE EVIDENCE SUGGESTS WE ARE
WINNING.
FOCUSING ON WORDS NOT DEEDS
REVEALS BIDEN'S IGNORANCE OF
SUCCESS.
LET'S HOPE THAT'S ALL HE REVEALS
LET'S HOPE THAT'S ALL HE REVEAL
REVEALS.
HMM INDEED.
IS HE GEARING UP?
HIS RHETORIC SORT OF MATCHES
THE LEFT TWINNING WITH THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THIS HYPERBOLE
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
MAYBE HE SHOULD BE BLOCKED.
MAYBE HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
POKING THE CAGE OF NORTH KOREA
AND MAKING US UNSAFE AND NO ONE
CAN SLEEP AT NIGHT.
HE IS APPEALING TO THAT MOOD,
THAT SORT OF PANIC, EUPHORIA
OVER TRUMP.
THEY GET EXCITED.
MAYBE THIS WILL BE IT.
ULTIMATELY I THINK JOE BIDEN IS
PROBABLY THINKING HE SHOULD HAVE
RUN INSTEAD OF HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Greg: HE HAS HAD MORE
GAFFES THAN A GAFFE MAKING
MACHINE.
NOW THE ARBITER OF THIS.
>> Dana: I THINK HE IS TRYING
TO PUT HIS TOE IN.
I THINK THAT'S WHY HE WAS
SPEAKING SO SLOWLY.
HE WAS TRYING TO BE CAUTIOUS IN
ELECTION.
I THINK WE JUST LEARNED THAT.
IT'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE HE'S NOT
GOING TO TALK TO OUR ENEMIES THE
SAME WAY HE TALKS TO THE
UNITED KINGDOM AND ITALY.
TALKING TO NORTH KOREA IS GOING
TO SOUND AND FEEL A LITTLE BIT
HOTLINE, MAYBE HOSTILITIES
DEEPENED.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD'VE HAD THE FLEXIBILITY TO
SAY THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
WE WILL BE PRAISING IT AND
SAYING IT'S RIGHT.
THEY ARE FLEXIBLE.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY KNOWS WHAT
THE END GAME IS HERE.
>> Greg: I THINK I KNOW IT.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE GREAT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kimberly: LEGO MOVIE.
EVERYTHING IS AWESOME.
>> Greg: FOR THE WORLD.
NOT NECESSARILY FOR ME.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BEEN VERY
PRESIDENTIAL.
HE IS A NEW AGE PRESIDENTIAL.
THAT'S WHAT JOE BIDEN IS MISSING
THAT'S WHAT JOE BIDEN IS MISSIN
MISSING.
HE WAS LOW-ENERGY.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THEM LIKE THAT.
IT WAS KIND OF RIDICULOUS AND TO
MISSILES IN POLAND.
HE WAS AGAINST "STAR WARS."
HE WAS AGAINST THE BIN LADEN
RAID.
HE WANTED TO DIVIDE IRAQ IN
THREE COUNTRIES.
HE WAS FOR RETREATING FROM IRAQ.
HE HAS NO LEGS TO STAND ON.
WHY ARE WE LISTENING TO
JOE BIDEN IN THE FIRST PLACE?
>> Geraldo: ISN'T IT NOT ABOUT
BIDEN?
IT'S ABOUT NORTH KOREA.
AS I SAID YESTERDAY, IT'S ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AGREED TO
SUSPEND THE JOINT MILITARY
EXERCISES WITH SOUTH KOREA,
IT MORE LIKELY THAT THE
MAKING MORE LIKELY THE JOINT
DELEGATIONS FOR THE LIPIDS.
NEW YORKERS ARE DIFFERENT.
VERY FLAMBOYANT NATURE.
THERE'S AN ASPECT OF HIM IN
TERMS OF THE CHARISMATIC REALITY
SHOW BACKGROUND HE HAS AND
PROMOTING BIG BUSINESS AND
CREATING BIG BUSINESS.
THERE'S AN ASPECT OF HIM THAT'S
A LOT OF FLASH BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE BANG, YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
HIS POLICY.
IN THIS CASE, IT'S TRADITIONAL,